Good morning, John; it's Tuesday, July 3rd.
How long am I gonna be on the odd days?
I'm tired of the odd days.
Out on the porch again on a porch swing.
So if I look like I'm constantly moving to you it's because I'm constantly moving.
Hopefully that's not going to make anybody nauseous.
In reference to your new nerdfighter scheme,
I am just mostly very happy
at the abilities of our current nerdfighters.
Because, damn!
I couldn't actually keep up with the
amazingness of the nerdfighters.
I went and had Brotherhood 2.0
sponsor a new person at kiva.org
and then, by the time I was done,
and had gone away to, you know, urinate
or something, I would come back
and it was already all the way funded.
People are really excited about this idea.
Which, I think that they should be.
However, you're right, there
could be more nerdfighters.
and more nerdfighters
would be a good thing.
I'm excited for all you new
senior executive nerdfighters.
I'm sure we will have
projects for you soon.
And don't worry. If you've seen more than
one episode of Brotherhood 2.0
you're not really a nit anymore.
You're a nerdfighter.
We'd love it if you'd comment more,
and I'd like to see you in my pants.
And rating our videos on YouTube
Getting "nerdfighter" tattooed across your face
Actually I seem to remember a point
in time where people were sending us
cool little nerdfighter things
that they were doing
like one person spelled "NERD FITR"
on their knuckles and sent us a picture
one person made an Easter egg that
said "nerdfighters" on it
I would like to encourage people to do that more.
Those made really good middle
frames for the YouTube clip.
Someone said they did sidewalk chalk
nerdfighters in their driveway.
Advertise yourself as a nerdfighter.
Do nerdfighter stuff,
uh, mostly just with
the word "nerdfighter",
and send it to us, and it's extremely
likely that it will be on the show.
I do have one other little bit
of business to attend to.
You do know what a Decepticon is, right?
You know, you didn't
make up that word.
Decepticons are Transformers,
the enemies of the Autobots.
When you chose Decepticons as
a name for a nerdfighter's enemy,
I initially thought that there must be
some better team of supervillains
to use as our enemies.
Then I looked, and I realized that
supervillains don't come in teams,
supervillains almost always work alone
with henchmen below them.
And the Decepticons are kind of a
gigantic exception to that rule.
I kept thinking of different villains
from cartoons from my childhood
Dr. Claw, Shredder, Mumm-Ra, Skeletor
you know, people like that.
But the Decepticons really are
a team of supervillains,
and I think that's impressive.
And frankly, as the enemy of
nerdfighters do operate in teams
they're not on their own.
They don't have henchmen.
I think Decepticons is, so far,
a pretty good name for them.
Anyhow, I will see you tommorow.